once upon a time i thought i was trying
to
rid my life of chaos and struggle i
thought that's why i was trying to get
rich and get the ferrari and the blonde
i thought that would create a life free
of free of struggle but then i looked at
some studies and i heard about this
thing called gold medal depression when
olympians come back from the olympics
and they've lost orientation and then
the day when someone offered to buy my
company for a
eight nine a nine figure number and it
filled me with this emptiness and this
dread and i i tried to understand the
role that struggle would would have to
play for me to be a fulfilled human
being for the rest of my life
yeah well that the observation with
regard to your company that's a that's a
great observation i mean
we're built to walk uphill
and
when you
reach the pinnacle of the hill you want
to stop and appreciate the vision but
the next thing you want is a higher hill
in the distance because
it's the uphill climb that
it's it's from the uphill climb that we
derive our value and i mean this
technically so almost all the positive
emotion we feel especially the the
the emotion that fills us with
enthusiasm and that's to be filled with
the spirit of god by the way because
that's what enthusiasm means
that's
experienced in relationship to a goal
and so in some sense and this is part of
the religious enterprise you want a goal
that you can never attain
right so you can always move closer to
the goal that recedes as you move
towards it you think well that's
frustrating it's like sisyphus pushing
the rock uphill but it's not because as
you pursue that goal you put yourself
together and your life does get better
and richer and more abundant that's why
the highest levels of virtue and goal
are in some sense transcendent you want
them to be above everything you're doing
so you can continually move towards
something that's more sublime and better
that's what you are you're here to live
not to
not to sleep
and the problem with the vision of my
ties on the beach is that well first of
all that's an envision that's a vision
of of drug induced
unconsciousness second it's only going
to work for about a week third you're
going to be a laughingstock in a month
and depressed and aimless
and and goalless it's no that's not it's
it's you want a horizon of ever
expanding possibility and so it does
happen to people as they because they've
staked their soul
on the attainment of an instrumental
goal and it can be a pretty high order
goal it was in your case but then you
think
well i've now i'm there now what
well the answer can't be well i'm going
to live in the lap of luxury and never
have to leave the fa what do you want to
be a giant infant with a gold with a
gold bottle you never have to do
anything but lay in your back and suck
it's like
well you see the problem with that as a
as a as a conceptualization it's no you
want to be
like an active warrior moving up hill
with your sword in hand and
that's that's dynamic that's exciting
and that's why so many young men
disappear into video games it's that's
all acted out in the video game
so they have to act that out in their
own life not that i despise video games
because i don't but they're not a
substitute for life they might be good
training under some conditions for life
so
[Music]
you